bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono quello che fai
video volevo spiegarvi che è da un botto
di tempo che mi consigliate in realtà
consigliate me lo state dicendo
minacciandomi di morte di portare parco
che in realtà io avevo scaricato già dal
tipo tre anni solo che esploso solo
ultimamente chi più del bon temps asp
accompagnarli in questa incredibile
avventura su tardo 321 questa è la
partenza è questa la prima partita e
facciamola questa voglia veramente nel
cestino che non c'è thomas ragazza non
c'è thomas senza thomas moio user
martino merito ed è claudio limitation
cose ma come si esce di qua farvi uscire
se premi una sola volta o ti dice da che
pare come si chiama dei posti da cui
uscire aspetta tanto muoio faccio prima
aspetto ma no non prova lo prova
uccidere proprio ucciderlo e ci sto
provando
erano in due e uccidono ottimo
incredibile
proprio lui l'altro si è incazzato lo
sente urlare no no no no
come si carica l'armani senza il pata
l'arma cristo come si carica carica
carica le armi nar vicari cavadonna un
gioco non di fps carica carica un'arma
come scarica le armi qua donna per un
gioco degli andarli a di ricarica
allarma così ricarica ricaricano arma ma
dio
minchia devono fare con sé madonne
impossibile ora ricaricata schiaccio
tutto programmare io il gioco madonna ho
capito che è un gioco reale ma cristo
un'arma dei ricaricarne che devo fà devo
costruire ma dai
mi ha sputato in un occhio su un uomo
morto se io ma dai ma io posso morire in
un gioco voglio morire perché sono
scarso non perché non riesco a
ricaricare un'arma perché non riesco a
prenderla da terra r ricarica badoer nei
ricarichi no no r no non ricarica va beh
allora fai ma hanno capito
avevo fatto una provata 1 luci erano in
21 ucciso un altro ci avevo davanti
tatami si impicciata l'armo detto noda è
mica ad ora cribbio mi guardano dal
cielo mi.sa mi dicono no non lo facciamo
uccidere due persone che già ora intanto
allora facciamo così la chan inceppare
l'arma inceppata l'arma ho dovuto
riprogrammare il gioco quelle iv quello
che ho studiato nell'informatica pelli
carica realmente il tema mentre me la
sono già fatta intenzioni bene per una
volta affascinava fatte bene
milano sca ma andiamo insieme
dall'italia barale ha sì mi butti
madonna quanto sei brutto mi butti
qualcosa per terra per favore come
valutarla 6 jason di vela di 13 o che ha
buttato questo con la effe lutti
allora la f cell abbiamo adesso manca il
tasso di ricarica il tasto per camminare
io non ho capito ma qua io sto caricando
di un fucile sto continuando a caricarlo
perché non far notizia state apprezzate
tappeto
ogni volta che tu ricarichi hub è la sua
arma non ti faccio vedere vieni vieni
qua ti faccio capire il realismo del
gioco passo io ho il caricatore con i
colpi pieni no se io ricarico guarda il
mio amico no che ciò per fortuna o lo
d'inventario pieno ok niente devo farti
vedere che a volte butta per terra il
caricatore perché a volte pax però lo
cambia con uno degli altri che già ci
sono
ok c'è un tipo c'è un tipo 100 innocenti
positivo la porta la giunta c'è un tipo
di sparo e uccise ci sono ci sarà un
player già incisa mannaia ed esperta
marito fuori dal casermone idou quello
che ho mangiato lì davanti a sé sì sono
io sono io sto per morire mannaggia sono
qua sono qua stiamo sparando a testa
questo compito di roba loro porca vacca
premi la prendi aiuola una roba è una
roba assurda questo però devo curarmi
seno muoio se io mi vedo l'ora di
riportare pensa al volare la situazione
sì sto perdendo vita ogni istante porte
quella va a quindi io prima mi sa che
sono morto non perché mi hanno sparato
ma perché sono questi dissanguato e
possibile questo mi sto mi sto curando
marca vacca o di sangue mi serve il
magistrato guardando il suo zaino
titolarissimo la vita mi cominciato che
ti muovi passano paraguay e soprattutto
quello dipende non cederò quindi a
brangelina e immediato nei movimenti
quindi difficile coprire
se vedono nel fare in tre secondi ci
mette un po di tempo ammirare a fare
l'eroe
ok che ha sparato si sta sparando es
essi della gente allora li hai preso
l'arma da quello fuori se ce l'ho ce
l'ho in mano la ridotta economico 4 tipo
44 lucido 5 nostro giocatore che
giocatore è lo fa fuori proprio lui il
tempo di morte morte ma devo studiati il
gioco c'è troppo lui cosa devo fare qua
aggiunte gente che il trotto roba cosa
facciamo cha cha
cosa facciamo adesso gli spara jaco
qualcuno ha sparato chi è che ha sparato
non e'la presenti e sentito sì se
dobbiamo fare brutta tutto quello che
poi ce ne andiamo ci leviamo dalle
scatole per un'acqua c'è gente questo
quali otto incendi sul secondo arrivasse
nome sparano questione secondo me è
arrivato a tutti ci ammazzano qua se si
fa aiutare da giardino vedove madonna mi
sto cambiando le mutande è che siamo
vicini per cortesia giappone qualcuno mi
ha colpito non lo so se non sbaglio è ma
più che altro mi arriva a zero e l'acqua
che succede dopo cardiff lui piace lo
sterno dietro quindi rai vostro curarmi
morirò il tempo è sono dati hanno
sparato chi che ti sparato e lo scarso e
chi me li ha seguiti calcio è strano no
ma chi ha sparato e se non c'è un
cecchino dei miei partito dove siamo
arrivati da dove siamo arrivati e grazie
che lui ha fatto fuori chissà dove
non so dove era andato a e la o morto
morto lucina macello lo vedi cosa un
altro sparo però allora prova andarla a
lottare dal cancello in mezzo alla
foresta dove siete
ok ok vediamo morto io sono qua io sono
quasi siccome non vi lascio correre
questo gioco perché come corno per
perché l'energia ed esiste anche
immediatamente il tizio mi raccomando di
volta che lutti premi xe rimane a tutto
il trattamento è sdraiato sopra l'altro
cadavere
ok quindi è la prima cosa che fai e cioè
trascini trascina anche ovviamente il
suo back che la sua best ce l'ha dentro
la tua devo prima esaminare tutto e poi
esatto esatto e poi dopo esami di che tu
abbia un arma questo questa una ramona
prima andare amici ci avviciniamo
madonna che cecchino della car ex1
qualcuno dopo il cancello adesso subito
no non ho la faccia
ecco quindi come sempre ho superato il
punto
no sono un altra parte del cancello
anche io non l'ho superato io adesso
arrivo che sono lo stanno vicino a te
non qui è però andato tipo qua dietro
occhio non solo dove però andato qua ma
un player di un player occhi attenti
sentito se si sta accucciato sta
accucciato annuncia poi la mano a
sinistra e ucciso non ci sono ciotola
schiavismo lo uccise qua
meno male che non ho sparato perché
riducono ma che sta dominando attenzione
era un player non aveva nulla vediamo
basta non c'è proprio nulla 01 nudo in
pratica uno qua
morto uno e moro vis uno morì lavativi
gli occhi e stata una cosa orribile
occhio essere inserite c'è qualcuno
quali so bene se sono lamentato davanti
a sto guardando la gas gas station
occhio severi po più avanti ci
incontriamo sanremo anno e mezzo ai
cespugli si sono delle spalle ad essi
sono io qua allora quasi 4 sinistra c'è
uno che è morto è morto lì in mezzo e
qualcuno è sparso location potrebbe
anche darsi che sia il cecchino sempre
lo stesso che ci ha fatto perché siamo
molto vicini alla zona dovevamo laddove
esso cecchino è qui da questa parte non
lo so non li ho studiati quindi cecchini
del gioco allora vuoi provare ad andare
a lottare quello la che morde o sei
pazzo è un bel ami avevi ha deciso di
james bond è invece esattamente all 1
i byte del
certo questa qua ho sparato io ho capito
una gamba e qua dietro il boiler lo
stonato mi ha colpito la gamba
attenzione e qua qua ha fatto ritirata è
un è un player colori a quello che
sparare nella sua immagine ha fatto
dietrofront subito perché non ha detto
ha in sé ma perché si dice così è visto
cosa ha un cecchino pesante però che
facciamo
il dominio quello colpito nelle palle
quindi qualcosa che avevo fatto io leroy
jenkins è leroy jenkins vai vai verso il
tizio subito un cecchino non posso
lasciar cesena sean utile bravo a
sinistra qua e qua che l'ha conosciuto
per terra è infatti volevo prendere ha
fatto lui nuovo se mi ha fatto mamma mia
o al cioccolato
no ho peccato lo ucciderlo
strano che per piacere catene ho provato
a svolgervi a sparargli però il mio
colpo non gli è arrivato è arrivato non
l'ha ucciso
anche lorenzo veramente si chiama
veramente fly che forse lorenzo
ragazzuoli spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto ha proseguito che faremo
sicuramente più pro bello mamma mia devi
solo imparare un po tutto il che è il 99
per cento di cose che ancora non
sappiamo però veramente figo
fatemi sapere se volete altri episodi
iscritti del canale sia da campanellino
e noi ci vediamo ragazzi
[Musica]